a
[Música]
el turismo en eeuu está prácticamente
paralizado las restricciones de viajes
impuestas por el gobierno de donald
trump cuando empezó la pandemia y que
aún están vigentes han hecho que algunas
industrias estén en serios problemas las
aerolíneas que se vieron obligadas a
cancelar la mayoría de sus rutas poco a
poco intentan volver a la normalidad a
medida que se reabre la economía pero no
hay viajes de negocios ni vacaciones y
hay miedo a volar por la posibilidad de
contagio así que en el país
norteamericano ya se ha anunciado más de
40 mil despidos en american airlines
delta y united la administración de eeuu
ha impulsado un paquete de estímulo
económico para estas empresas en total
se van a destinar más de 25 mil millones
de dólares con un objetivo principal
evitar los despidos masivos sin embargo
expertos financieros advierten que el
sector turístico está viviendo una
crisis sin precedentes y es muy probable
que incluso algunas aerolíneas se vean
obligadas a desaparecer ante la
incapacidad de llevar una operación
empresarial que no está funcionando a
pleno rendimiento
[Música]
pocas semanas después de haberse
conocido que el cob y 19 había llegado a
irán a comienzos de febrero el gobierno
anunció una ayuda de 87 millones de
dólares en préstamos para las aerolíneas
que están divididas en dos grandes
bloques una son muy pequeñas que cubren
las rutas nacionales que aunque han
estado abiertas se han reducido en su
transporte un 50% en los últimos meses y
las otras dos son las dos grandes
aerolíneas una pública que es iranair y
la otra privada mahan pero es que son
las que cubren las rutas internacionales
desde irán y que han sido las más
afectadas pues si bien algunas de esas
rutas se han abierto el tránsito es muy
poco y se dice que se ha reducido un 91
por ciento en el transporte de pasajeros
lo que hace aún más crítica la situación
de estas aerolíneas que vienen desde
hace años siendo afectadas por las
sanciones económicas con las que está
sometida irán
[Música]
las reiteradas peticiones de políticos
no solamente aquí en alemania sino
también en otras partes de europa para
que la gente no viaje en estas épocas y
así pueda reducir las posibilidades de
contagio no ha hecho sino aumentar esa
sensación de crisis en el sector de las
aerolíneas aquí en alemania en
particular en lufthansa que es la
principal del país hace unos meses
lufthansa llegó a un acuerdo con el
gobierno nacional para un
multimillonario paquete de rescate
evaluado en unos nueve mil millones de
euros pero esto no ha impedido que en
las últimas semanas continúen los
titulares negativos sobre lufthansa que
tuvo que anunciar nuevas medidas de
ahorro sustancia anunció la reducción de
su flota la cancelación de puestos de
trabajo y eso sin contar que unos 650
mil viajeros continúan esperando que se
les devuelva su dinero por viajes
cancelados un tema todo esto muy
preocupante no solamente a nivel
económico sino también a nivel político
pues el acuerdo alcanzado hace unos
meses llevó a que el gobierno nacional
se convierta
en uno de los principales accionistas de
lufthansa
[Música]